the cost of living continuing to soar
figures from the british
retail consortium show that the
inflation on shop prices has also nearly
doubled since december the latest
figures today show shoppers have been
hit by the highest price rises in almost
10 years after shop inflation almost
doubled over the last month with more
and more people struggling to afford the
essentials savvy shopping has become
very important
let's talk about it with gemma godfrey
from the times money mentor hi gemma
thanks for joining us have you got
examples for us
so i do because what we're seeing is is
that the average uh weekly shop for our
groceries is increasing by between 15
and 25 so if we look at you know your
average bag of pasta so for 500 grams it
was costing about 50p a year ago
actually two years ago in 2020
and it's now costing 70p and that's a
rise of a quarter and the reason is is
bad weather has affected and the
harvesting of the wheat that's in pasta
if you look at milk milk has been a
complete and perfect storm so that's
also risen in cost by about a quarter
over the last two years and the reason
is you've got gas prices rising that's
increasing the price of fertilizer which
is making it more expensive to feed
cattle you've also got labor costs
increasing and machinery costs
increasing and you've got rising demand
while supply is falling as dairy farming
and the likes of new zealand is being
cut because of environmental
issues so that's up 4p for every pint
you've also got coffee
so we've got some coffee here
and there you've seen droughts and
you've seen the worst frost in brazil
for over two decades while the cost of
shipping has risen by two and a half
times so that's obviously impacted that
price and actually a lot of retailers
have been holding back price increases
we're starting to see that feed through
and finally which i'm sure
viewers will resonate with when we saw
when we were at the beginning of the
pandemic
the price of toilet paper is
significantly increasing and you've seen
ceos of
toilet paper um making companies come
out and say they've held back for as
long as they could because what we've
seen at home is um we're at home more
we're obviously using paper products
more we're also using cardboard more for
the delivery of goods as well as having
um transport issues with truck driver
shortages and the cost to transport are
also increasing and companies are having
to start to feed that through and that's
really going to impact people at a time
when national insurance is rising the
government's support is being withdrawn
so it's making it very very tough
fascinating stuff thanks very much gemma
thank you for making that
straight forward for us much appreciated
larry williams single mom struggling
with the rising cost of living is with
us now hi larry thanks for joining us
tell us about your current situation and
how you're coping
um hello good morning um i'm on um
universal credit um i work in the events
industry or i did before um covid um but
uh obviously we've had a massive
knock-on effects in the events industry
there and because of low income on one
universal credit um i have a tiny bit of
child maintenance and child benefit and
that's what i have to live on which
doesn't actually cover all the bills
can you give us any idea on on numbers
and how you're coping or i mean just
tell us what as much as you want to and
you tell us what you want to tell us
okay okay um single parent and so
obviously trying to run a house on um
i'd say at what average house cost to to
actually pay for everything is about
probably 1800 2 000 a month
and i'm probably getting about seven
eight hundred a month at the moment
wow okay so
yeah
yeah
i'm sorry to interrupt you there uh
larry i was just wondering what you've
had to cut back on
um i've had to cut back on everything
and i just i heard you say about the
savvy shopping um
for example so when i get my money in so
for example universal credit or child
maintenance going goes in i immediately
go and fill the car up um
i make sure i pay my mortgage um gas and
electric come out of universal credit so
i make sure that they're paid because
their priority bills anything else then
whatever's left out of the money um
literally pays for any of the house
bills um the way i'm living at the
moment um
i have in the past used food banks
um but jitter covered and my pensioner
father having to be feds i i managed to
get him uh morrison's orders
so um every time i do him in order i do
an order for me so we've we have food
and i know the food bank's there um god
forbid anything happened to my dad i've
been a completeness a mess
um and it seems pretty bad that you know
i'm having to rely on my dad's 80 85
year old father for for just
basic living really
um gas electric comes straight out of
universal credit so i don't have any
control of what they take
um so for example universal credit um
person like me
single mum my age
is i think there's about 653 they pay a
month
so from that immediately uh there's
about 100 or 200 go straight to gas and
electric
67 to a budgetary loan that i had
because i didn't have any money and i
needed some extra
which leaves me roughly 300 pounds
that's my mortgage well my dad's paying
some of the mortgage as well because
he's just trying to keep me and my
daughter afloat really
um so yeah you can you can see the
numbers so
taking the 80 pound office um you know
the government's done is is
it's food it that allowance is literally
food so the amount of people struggling
at the moment to end this um across the
events in literature as well um i'm on a
couple of campaigns and all we've been
doing is trying to raise money to
actually keep people fed
yeah larry i i don't know um how you
begin to cope thank goodness your dad is
there for you at the moment hopefully
things will start to get a little bit
better for you going forward um maybe
you won't have to pay as much for those
um
energy bills when we when we get into
the warmer months but hopefully people
are listening and um your case and so
many others around the country will be
listened to by the government thank you
for taking the time to join us thank you
thank you